es versprach ein großer und fröhlicher
tag auf die monat zu werden die pipe man
kann ja das ist das geilste kate alter
wie geil oh mann ich freue mich richtig
drauf ist einzusetzen doch dann
hallo ich bin es als ob wieder am hacken
ist wie der am hacken ist
ssg sind herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge die dümmsten kids auf timo
lia und wie immer sind wir hier auf
kino.de für alle die das format noch
nicht kennen ist ja kein wirkliches
formal ich mache es ja erst zum zweiten
mal das ist die zweite folge
logischerweise wir gehen hier in die
warteschlange und schauen uns an was
auch für kids kommen mit
get the guitar klick
und hier hinten noch ein feiertag
okay die polka auf die 42 genau ein
pfeil ist im internet
haben ob ich heute morgen gern auf zwei
bitte mein mikro ist gerade bisschen im
weg hieß es dass gleich raus zu ihr ich
gesagt
der läuft ja auch eine richtig schöne
bogen gesagt
okay da das richtig gegeben hammerhart
ich habe angst ich meine hand ist direkt
neben dem mikrofonkabel und das kann man
einfach so raus ziehen uns nicht fixiert
leider deswegen ist das bisher kritisch
ich werde es euch wie immer zusammen
schneiden die lustigsten runden nehmen
und dann am ende kommt wie immer dass
das jüngste kind des heutigen tages
erwartet euch ja wie immer am ende und
es sind ziemlich viele angel papier habe
ich gefühlt
okay das war auch knapp ein bisschen
bessere range gehabt und haben ein zwei
double jetzt austeilen können das hat
ihm das hat ihn sein leben gekostet ok
eine pause damit auch sehr gut komme
gegen die preußen einsetzen
ist keine schlechte idee so ein eimer
milk einzupacken habe ich noch nicht
dran gedacht ehrlich gesagt
ja
ich ganz gern die pausen porsche nämlich
ansätzen hat getroffen oder
hey ich sehe keine preiseffekte als ob
diese promotion gerade nicht getroffen
hat
das dauert kann mir keiner erzählen dass
die puschen gar nicht getroffen hätte
was zur hölle die war doch genau in
seine fraser oder ordner fakt ist gerade
stream ja
okay leute jetzt sind wir wieder bei
einem sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
behinderten geht was zur hölle
protection vor wasser schützen die feile
bitte warum kommt man
hier
ja jetzt geht's wieder jetzt ist tiefer
als ob wie macht ihr so viel schaden
wahrscheinlich hat er auf ein scharfes
und feiere gepackt okay okay aber den
effekt habe ich dann lasst uns loslegen
der bau hat infiniti darauf auch
das ist auch ein entfernter
ok hätte das hab ich das habe ich getan
hat ist der dorn drauf auf der rüstung
vor uns sehr stolz drauf wusste ich ja
wusste ich doch weil man da irgendwie
doch schaden bekommen dazu gerade als
ich denke habe ich schon bekommen
day
nicht schließen okay das sind aber
begrenzt frei
ps extra
gewartet bis zurück das nutzen
wunderbar
oha da kriege ich wieder kompliment ich
bin i / tel einfach private nachrichten
reagieren weil sowas passiert immer hier
auf timo ja also es ist noch geiler als
escape beste
was echt ist nein
da bin ich jetzt mit einem die runde
gekommen der mich kennt und in sein
schwert es kay beste genannt hat aber
noch mit aaa nicht mit lte
ich hoffe der bwsg best zerstören
wo ich bin grad nicht so in der optimale
ausgangssituation muss ich sagen
ja es ist wahr wir wollen empfiehlt
ecowas und ich klicke mich rüber in
youtube alter jetzt bin ich auf youtube
gerade
moment einem anderen hier so sagt sagt
auch noch programme haben wir viel herz
nannte 05 herzen dass man so der fall
mit meinem eigenen
erschwert was heißt wie ich folge von
eis alter habe ich voll die fanbase auf
dem pvp server und hat die leute die
sagen dass ich es bin
oder wer macht es gut
kurz mal checken was sache so geht in
seinem leben
hpg erwischt mit einer steinachs auch
sehr gut interessante sache eigentlich
auf jeden fall mit der sonne standards
zu kämpfen hier sind wir noch ein pc
hilfe der penetrieren algerien
penetrieren und die petri helfer und
einen typen mit dem abgefahrenen nahmen
die gastgeber zwar gerne das weißt du
auch dass wir die moritz kassiert man
der story sehr schön sehr gut sehr gut
sehr gut manchmal bringt es nämlich echt
wirklich einfach in die offensive zu
gehen und nicht zu warten und zu
rückwärts zu laufen und kid und gift
trend zu schmeißen lava zu setzen weil
wenn eine richtig durchzieht ist einer
mitteilung gut leute herzlich beim zu
kippen
was ich überhaupt nicht an eu
ok schauen wir doch
okay so
kalt wie sieht wie sich alle so viel
mühe geben ihre kids zu benennen das
finde ich so nah ist der ccc hacker
infiniti punch hob an
the world ist in harbin pushen ist auf
dem posten er ist aber meistens ein
bisschen zu sehr am kotten er sollte
mehr guck erst gesehen ist die ganze
darüber dass gelaufen und hat deswegen
die derbsten hits passiert und jetzt
verloren und ich war die ganze zeit viel
zu nah am mikro
hättest es ist halt auch immer asozial
ok infiniti schaffens 1 projekt
protection die pappe man kann ja das ist
das geilste kate alter wie geil und ich
freue mich richtig drauf ist anzusetzen
und co
hey lass ich glaube wichtig ja nicht
dass mich mein pferd steigen
gibt es mich jetzt es gibt ja immer noch
nicht dieses dieser blöde drexler ja
okay es ja schließlich will auch das
pferd steigen das nicht nein würde
ich nicht
nein nicht abwerfen warum man muss so
lange auf dem weg zum klettern bis es
eigentlich mehr abwirft
er kommt als ob was ist für das pferd
das sind doch irgendwann anfang nicht zu
bieten hallo
herr diana
und jetzt könnt ihr im sattel aufziehen
jetzt geht es
wie geil bekämpft werden haben wir ja
und er gab seinen fertig kämpfen weil
das nicht gezähmt hat bitte bitte und
wiesen auf ein schnelles ja ja ich sehe
ihn zwar nicht egal wie geil das ist ja
wie sie mit zehn
mann
hammergeil alter dass das ist richtig
geil es geht erstmal die schicken
spawnen wie immer ganz wichtig leute
kurzen kurz cross checks machen
funktioniert nicht weil sie zu wenig
leben haben hatte ich mir die verbrennen
gar nicht die sterne für direct auch ihr
job
hallo ich bin's als ob wieder am hacken
ist wie der am hacken ist und da fragt
was war das gerade
was was was ist mit dem los
was ist mit dem
alle ganz schwere behinderung also
denker der hexer deutet nicht gerade
die hexen natürlich gehören sozusagen so
leute das war's von heutigen folge ich
hoffe es hat euch wie immer gefallen ich
muss echt noch mal sagen danke für die
resonanz auf die letzte folge das war
hammerhart das ist mein video mit der
besten zuschauer bin echt also das hat
euch richtig gefallen scheinbar und
deswegen machen der nächste folge für
euch ist ja klar ich hoffe ja doch spaß
mit den kids und ja lasst wie immer
leicht da scheint mir die kommentare was
sie gezahlt wird von den ganzen namen
die sich die leute daraus gesagt haben
wir sehen uns auf jeden fall im nächsten
video wieder haut rein macht gut und